this partnership is not just a political
one it is much more than that the
European Union and select jointly
account for one third of the world
countries together we can have a
decisive impact on just to bring a few
examples the global climate talks the
post-2015 development agenda in the
fight against drugs climate change
matters to ask both Latin American and
Caribbean countries are very vulnerable
to this threat that's one reason that
the Paris talks later this year have to
succeed
we also discussed international and
regional security we are building a
partnership of equals based on mutual
benefit and mutual respect the direct
fibre of the cable that we agreed to
build between our two continents is
perhaps a simple but nonetheless strong
symbol of our ever closer connection
European Union has always supported
civic and the European Union will
continue to support our friends that's
reason why the Commission has announced
over 800 billion in support for the
region in the last two days we know that
Europe has gone through two horrendous
world wars but with a political will in
place they've managed to unite however
in Latin America we have everything in
common language history culture and it's
now time we consolidate our union and I
think that Europe offers us a great
example
we all agreed with the proposal that in
December in Paris we have to make sure
we have a binding agreement not just
mere statements or declarations but we
have to legally binding agreement with
contributions from all countries we have
to take care of the only planet that we
have and combat the pandemic of climate
change the EU and C Lac are two regions
which share
fundamental principles so the supremacy
of international law human rights
democracy the right to all humanity to
be able to live well and dignity we
continuing to work on those principles
and we hope to continue this very much
into the future thank you once again
presidents